news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
okay i really need everybody to
understand this because this is so
important
the strategy by donald trump of saying
that the election will be
unfair and rigged is working
if it wasn't convincing anybody we could
ignore it
it might be no big deal but it is
working donald trump has convinced
65 percent of republican voters
that the upcoming election might not be
fair
this is a poll based on more than 44
000 u.s adults with a one percent margin
of error
now here's what makes this really tricky
65 percent of republicans question
whether the election will be fair
46 percent of democrats also aren't
confident that the election will be fair
but the devil is in the details because
the concerns about fairness
from republicans are very different than
the concerns about fairness
from the democrats and it really comes
down to understanding these details
republicans who think the election might
not be fair
are falling for what donald trump has
been saying which is
mail-in ballots will be riddled with
fraud we won't know the election results
for a long time
they are rigging it that's what the
republican voters have fallen for
democrats on the other hand are worried
that
trump is making the election not fair by
breaking the post office by filing
lawsuits by trying to suppress the vote
so on and so forth preventing vote by
mail
purging voter rolls doing all of the
things that republicans have been doing
for decades to try to win elections by
suppressing the vote
so these are not asymmetrical concerns
if you
glance at the numbers and you say okay
well it seems like republicans are
democrat
and democrats are basically in agreement
just to slightly different degrees
46 percent of dems think the election
might be unfair
65 percent of republicans no big deal
slight party difference
the reasons why they think there might
not be fairness are what is so
dramatically different and what you
have to understand in order to really
synthesize this properly
is the history of voter suppression
historically
democrats try to increase voter turnout
period
they just say if more people vote were
better off in general
republicans have employed a strategy of
trying to
limit voter turnout in very particular
and specific ways
polling shows that it's trump
who will most likely or more likely need
foul play in order to win democrats
simply want the election to happen
they want everybody who wants to vote to
get to vote and they want every single
one of those votes to be counted
and it's true if that happens it's
better for joe biden we know that to be
true
the president is the one who realizes
that he might
need voter fraud and voter suppression
to win
as i told you in the last segment and
the scariest thing is that it's working
for donald trump our concern for a long
time has been
if it's close in november and trump
claims it was rigged and it activates
his followers many with their guns to
hit the streets that could get very
ugly and it could happen very quickly it
could happen within hours
of whenever trump claims the rigging
took place so
when we hear that there are you know
gaps in the confidence people have in
our voting systems
we can't forget that one side is the
side that tries to lower turnout
in order to win meaning a ton of
trumpists
are happy that the election might not be
fair
this has always been the point of
attacking it and this is why
it will continue unless we stop it this
is how it starts this is how you
weaponize people to hit the streets
maybe with guns to demand that you be
kept in power these are not
inconsequential or trivial matters
now what can we do if you want to find
out
how and where you can vote early check
out the page called
early voting by state on vote.org we're
linking to that page
in the description to the youtube video
for this story and you will very quickly
see that
every state is different here in
massachusetts for example early voting
starts 11 days
before this is in-person early voting
starts 11 days before the election
in michigan it starts 45 days before the
election we're getting close to that
um in florida it's early voting starts
at least 10 days before the election if
not earlier so
understand that understand what the
rules are
for voting absentee in your state you
probably in most states you probably
already
can request an absentee ballot i've
already done it i've received my primary
ballot for the september first election
and sometime after september 1st i'm
going to be receiving my absentee ballot
for the general election in november
understand all of these things
figure out how you plan to vote and then
let's activate
whoever we can and make sure that people
that are already on our side plan to
vote particularly when
you know trump wants to make it
difficult to vote but the reality is in
most states it's actually easier
than ever to vote with early voting with
expanded absentee ballot access there's
no excuse for not voting this time
around and many people
metaphorically this time around are
willing to
crawl over broken glass in over in order
to vote
some would literally do it i'm using it
metaphorically